what is your opinion I just I just think
Andrew Tate is a overall net positive
for men because for the last decade Plus
everywhere a man goes on television on
movies in music and in video games and
social media they're just [__] on
men non-stop I went back to America
recently and I watched television and I
watched the commercials and everything
is clearly geared to financially
extorting women under the guise of like
female empowerment and I just can't
believe that they fell for the shed like
especially when you have all these
American women like saying like we're
better than men we're better than men
yet we're at press at the same time
Andrew Tate's only mistake that he made
was he trusted American woman and got it
locked out for six months in [__]
prison so that's the one big mistake he
made but other than that you know I
think that this whole situation
um to be optimistic about it it's really
an eye-opening situation for a lot of
men because there are like hundreds of
millions of men watching this case and
being like yo I trusted this [__]
hoes and now I'm locked up in a Romanian
prison and uh you know it's not and if
that happened to him he's got money
power status what happens to the average
guy that's what he was saying today on
the on the valuetainment interview he
was saying what happened what happens to
like you know Bob the plumber or like
you know Joe the electrician like it's
really awful to see this but also like
as as much as Nativity and garbage that
he's gone through look at how despite
the massive unfair social media
cancellation that he's gone through look
at how he has still been ever been able
to overcome this while on house arrest
he was tweeting from prison and still
pissing people off and red pilling
people harder so yeah I mean you know
he's he is I mean if they try to kill
him too all they're going to do is make
a massive martyr out of him right so you
know I just I want nothing but the best
for the guy I think he's going to get
out okay and if they do slap him with
something you know it's just going to be
people
seeing like a massive Injustice in the
world and that's just going to piss off
the masses more and wake more people up
to the treachery of government the
elites and all this [__] so you think
that there's no smoke without fire is
that something that is really in your
life because I will say something yeah
I've noticed that usually men that are
in a position of high test or in
whatever type of career whether it's
fighting whether it's you know a
military guy whatever the case is and
you become really powerful usually you
kind of attract the certain toxic sides
of the masculine World whether it's
going to be involvement with drugs
whether it's going to be involvement
with prostitution where it's going to be
involvement with guns whatever right
he's gone down the e-pimp route okay
which for me I'll tell you right now
with the type of profile that he has the
type of people that he will be with the
even in fact being in Romania there is
no smoke without fire I'm not saying
that he is guilty but I'm just saying
listen don't paint somebody to be an
angel just because you like what he says
because I know for a fact by
understanding his profile seeing
certainly all hints he's got a very dark
past and he's catching up with him now
he's cleaned up his image fantastic
that's great well done but there's stuff
there's a skeleton skeletons in the
closet that perhaps are starting to
catch up with her skeletons in
everyone's closet it depends on the type
of skeleton though you've got skeletons
in your closet too everybody got skilled
and and his past is not catching up with
him these are recent women that put him
in jail who they have on documentation
on WhatsApp
coordinating this and saying how are we
going to [__] get false allegations
against this man how are we going to put
this man in prison how can we lie cry
and manipulate the authorities social
media the mainstream media in order to
put this man in prison and raise
ourselves up those women are pieces of
[__] in every sense of the world and
there's videos of them luxury shopping
like like being so they're saying they
were they were forced to be there and
there's videos of them luxury shopping
while they're there it's like okay we're
in a world where they can just make one
accusation another in prison for six
months yeah and I just say something
um again going back to the Andrew Tate
thing again he has amazing ideas but
this is why uh what I why I felt like
his whole idea of forget marriage don't
get married and just have million
different girlfriends it's just led to
his downfall and I just wanted to speak
out and say like men don't fall into
this trap or thinking that having you
know hoes is like you know life and like
when you just have one woman and you
settle down with that person you can
avoid a lot of problems but I'll tell
you the problem is women don't want to
settle down it's not it's yes they no
they don't because here's the thing okay
men want young women to marry they want
like they would prefer like the ideal is
a young virgin right when women are
young virgins they don't choose to
settle down when women have the most
power in the marketplace the most Beauty
and the most youth they choose
non-monogamy women choose to get married
in their 30s here the average age of
first marriage in the UK is 31 do men is
a 31 year old bride ideal for most men
no but I feel like someone like Andrew
Tate could have found that 20 year old
virgin it's not hard especially he has
because he has a lot of power he's
married he is married yeah and actually
I'm going to correct you on that he
doesn't say go out there and womanize
and stuff he says if you find a good
woman hold on to her okay you know if
you find a good woman keeper and I he
does also say that like endlessly
chasing hoes is a waste of time because
hoes are hoes they're no value you know
you're going to grow old and you're
going to be some old man in the club
like chasing hoes but he contradicted
himself in the end don't you think no
he's not because he has a wife and
children but he's not he has he has the
very thing you say he is anti-agance but
didn't he have hoes too that where are
all these women coming from I'm confused
something was every single one of them
lying let me add something to what you
said it's like because Andrew is a very
famous person so he's just like in the
media everyone is in his business every
guy most percent of guys out there when
you have money to just [__] around sorry
they just yeah they just F around even
broke guys do it yeah it's like
um those girls who actually caught to
those apartments they had a choice to
say no but he's spending money on them a
lot of girls go for that do you know
what I mean like so that does not make
him a bad person it's just because he's
famous then people are like in his
business all this this but like do you
know what I mean and does he chase women
or do the women chase them have you ever
seen a very like attractive successful
guy the women come to them they don't
have to do [__] like have you seen like
a professor National athletes there are
women that buy hotels at every game
trying to get them to cheat on their
wives like that is their full goal
there's like it'll be like the hottest
22 year olds you've ever seen in your
life sitting on the sideline saying
we're down for a three like this is the
thing that the guys get thrown at them
every single let me add them I used to
work at the Amway arena in Orlando right
for the Orlando Magic awful basketball
team and these chicks would wait outside
the arena
for these players to be walking to their
cars walking to the bus or whatever and
try to get these like third and fourth
Stringer dudes because the league
minimum in the NBA at the time was
almost 400 000 a year and these girls
are trying to get baby daddy's status
from these dudes you know what I mean so
they're a lot then let's be real you
girls know there are a lot of predatory
hoes out there yeah yeah come on and
you're here in London and that's my
first time here and I could just tell
you because that's a thing around the
world you know so I think what he's
trying to tell is the same thing I tell
my message is that when a guy learns
game it's not to go out there and date a
bunch of women although you can but
ultimately
is to identify a woman that's good for
you and a woman that's bad for you so
when you know the woman's bad for you
it's pumping dump or you know when a
woman's good for you and she shows
herself be of value you take care of her
you make sure she's solid if she needs
stuff you take care of her after she's
proved her worthiness how is the guy
supposed to know the difference if he
hasn't had experience yeah and that's
the problem is like a lot of girls like
got like you've seen it right I'm sure
you guys all know a girl where her
boyfriend has no idea she was a hoe two
years ago right like yeah she's she's
smiling yeah yeah yeah and and so
because the guys that are young and
naive they have no idea like women just
have so much more power when they're
young because any any of us can open our
Instagram we have you know a million
messages where it's like a young guy he
has to work and earn that and the
problem is it's just such an unfair
Dynamic where women can actually be
predatory and kind of pull one over on a
guy like a lot of guys want to get
married young but the problem is the
women when we have all the power this is
what we choose to do
I have a question
um I actually love Andrew T I just want
to test you guys a little bit
um I just feel like with um this is why
men don't trust women
do you have a lot of questions I want to
like hear from you guys opinion but I
feel like with Andrew Tate okay say this
say for example your son came to you and
said to you um Dad I'm in jail because I
slept with this girl and she lied on me
are you now gonna say I feel so much
sympathy for you or are you gonna tell
your son actually you're in the wrong
for not noticing the difference between
a trick and a good woman why did you
sleep with her and that's my problem I
feel like a lot of people are having
sympathy what about a girl that gets
graped she gets graped you're in the
wrong you didn't know the difference
between a Grapist and a normal guy yeah
but no no no answer answer which one
sorry repeat the question if your
daughter gets raped do you not and are
you gonna come to her when she comes to
you and say do you not know the
difference between a Grapist and a
normal guy no I'm not going to say but
so why why is it when it's men
with men someone like Andrew Tate he has
more power and he goes on a platform and
he preaches learn the difference between
the good woman and that woman now the
whole downfall of his platform is him
choosing to deal with women who weren't
really so what if the woman's a dating
coach
so if she's a dating coach and gives
dating advice and then gets graped or is
it on her now because she didn't know
the difference I just I don't really
care if that's what you think I just
hope you have the same energy for women
and that's my point is like women don't
really feel Sympathy For Men I feel
sympathy for women but not men do you
know what the problem is I think that
people nowadays they're just not
selective enough both on the women
silent on the men's side even the men
that have got all these Bugattis and
money and they can have any girl that
they want they are still not selective I
hang out with some people yeah and I go
to some of these places that there's
powerful people that I'm looking at
these men and what they're doing and I'm
disgusted I'm like ew all that power and
all that money for you to just give it
away to any old thing out there that is
right to open her legs but I think be
selective otherwise you're getting the
problem is men can't be that is think
think about what I said okay no think
about think about 90 of women have been
at Birth Control at some point in their
life remember the ideal woman if we're
gonna go back to like what men
biologically want is a young virgin in
right 95 of women have been on or 90 of
women have been on birth control 90 um
the average partner count and this is
including older women so it's probably
lower when you look at younger women is
between five to eight men which
historically would have been completely
Haram that's a lie yeah okay this is
just what the numbers and I say that way
one out of three women has had an
abortion one out of three women have an
STD so it's like this is even if you
become a one percent guy they don't
expect virgins because they're not
really there and even if they find one
they don't know if she's telling the
truth yeah but this is not in virginity
selective is in substance the sort of
substance of women
you're looking at Women's you're looking
at Women's standards but like this is
what men value they value Purity they
value youth that's what no no no I'll
tell you this one and they're still
banging big things a big thing a very
top thing that men value above all thing
is sexual Purity we do not want to
imagine the woman we love taking a shot
on the face face or getting dominated by
any other dude or you know being a part
of a gang bang or whatever goes on those
sororities we don't want to deal with
that it's not our ideal you would do it
to other women that's what it's crazy
so the average guy the average guy hold
on hold on the average guy which you
girls most likely ignore doesn't do that
ignore so but then guess what who gets
the coverage is the top G's that can get
anything so most guys want to be like
that people you have to understand
they're adapting to the market most guys
are young and they start they they start
off really sweet and what they're doing
is they're looking for a young wife that
wants to get married or try to treat her
well and they find out that when they
treat girls well they don't get laid but
we can say the same thing for women I
think the reason why women and listen
the thing is with if women no wrong
wrong wrong because no no because you're
gonna say something with women like do
the same thing that's what you said and
that's wrong because if women did the
same thing we would have more to offer
but the average modern woman doesn't
have my much to offer to men in terms of
what men value if women did so much they
would stay pure for their husbands we
don't we would know how to cook we don't
I think the average girl buried young we
don't I think they don't they don't have
a concept of like healthy boundaries
that a guy naturally knows like not
talking or keeping communication with
men you've slept with in the past that's
like a big No-No for guys like because
we we know that that dude is just a
predator just sitting around waiting for
his chance to get another taste
I understand that one modern women today
are just like trash basically but
sometimes not all of them not all of
them they are good there are good women
out there yeah there are good women out
there but the mainstream is showing that
women are trash but I think the problem
is historically none of the like 95 of
women would be disqualified that's
that's the crazy when you think about it
like in terms of the last Thousand Years
95 of women today would be disqualified
do you know what you said earlier you
said how would a man know which girl to
pick if she hasn't if he is not
experienced it goes the same wave to a
woman how would she know what kind of
man is a certain manner
okay is Mom then and this is the thing
these women women are dumb oh God
think about it when women are in charge
of her own mate selection so so the last
hundred years what's different is women
are now in charge of mate selection that
has never happened in all of history
it's always been the families and the
fathers so now that women have more
control the most control ever of made
selection what has happened our mate
choices are terrible when we have the
most power to choose entertainers
rappers like it's it's it even if it's
not like a worldwide celebrity like so
many women date rappers in their 20s
entertainers in their 20s basketball
players so it's like these men are not
monogamous they're not typically like
the traditional husbands but I feel like
for me personally the problem with these
type of conversations where people say
like women modern women are falling off
and so on and so forth is that they
don't really talk about why women are
falling off women are falling off is
because men fell off men were becoming
weak dads were not in the home no more
men who's kicking the dads out of the
homes
whose initiated
the number two reasons I can't remember
what they were but it was like when that
started to happen which was like the 70s
and 80s Rachel if you're in the town let
me know what they were but it's it's
babe it was like emotional like just not
being happy emotional differences yeah
it was one of the top two women get
divorced for stupid reasons and listen
listen listen so you girls that are
you're mad you girls can all agree that
the Modern Men right now you really
don't like them right
so the panel right here is pretty
unanimously across they don't like what
these guys are depends on the modern man
you're going for because like there's
some good guys out there and then
depends on what you like the kind of
places you go to the kind of people you
mingle with yeah that's the kind of men
you're gonna make if you like hanging on
the hood going clubbers every single
time you're gonna meet a stupid guy no
offense some of them are good
I want to add on to my point real quick
the point I'm trying to say is this
right so you guys are dissatisfied with
the state of the modern man it seems
unanimously the majority of these men
are raised by women
okay and what and what motivates me
so if if the quality of men like
decreased maybe it's because the reward
at the end like what does a guy think
about it most guys want a genetic Legacy
right and so let's let's say they find
the good woman to to start a family with
they have no guarantee she won't leave
because divorce is legal and so what's
at the end of this for him